clair que ce sera très important d'avoir
une transition ou vite et est très
efficace
comme vous avez mentionné c'est un temps
économique très difficile
je suis confiant que la banque a
plusieurs transitions à julie confiant
que ça va aller de manière très efficace
l'institut cédéao estime que le canada
est déjà en récession la définition
classique d'une récession c'est une
contraction de 2 trimestres consécutifs
de l'économie l'institut définit plutôt
une récession comme étant une baisse
prononcée persistante généralisé de
l'activité économique en se basant
principalement sur l'évolution du pib de
l'emploi les données pour le mois de
mars sont tellement mauvaise qu'il ne
fait aucun doute que le pays est en
récession selon l'institut avec nous
clément gignac économiste en chef de
l'industrielle alliance bonsoir clément
gignac
bonsoir vous avez travaillé avec tiff
macklem au ministère des finances à
ottawa 2008-2009 parlez parlez nous un
peu de lui oui je supprime la janvier
positive donc je dépanne serment dans
secret des dieux mais je serais pas
surpris qu'on arrête de jouer sur tes
cheveux puisque et année son expérience
c'était lui qui était l'architecte de la
réponse canadienne la crise financière
de 2008 et 2009 comme sous ministre
associé donc en plus de son expérience
il ya de 80 finalement une star et
financecom souvenez s'associe également
de premiers secours mais de 2010 à 2014
la band cadeau c'était le constat est
idéal parce que naît tout les outils
dans le coffre à outils que ce soit des
outils de nature monétaire les connais
tous donc hélas est un conte une crise
sans précédent
ça prend quelqu'un qui connaissait
sociaux noir pour et des milices des
finances est ce que vous pensez parce
que tout le monde pensait que ça allait
être caroline wilkens beaucoup de gens
pensaient cela c'était la favorite est
ce que vous pensez que le fait que nous
sommes dans une crise et qu'il a
travaillé sur la crise financière et est
venu changer la donne
j'en suis convaincu sans les vrilles
le capacité d'expertisé madame wilkens
évidemment mais le fait que lui est il
arrivé que ses connaissances là du côté
fiscal et budgétaire c'est très
important je travaille également dans le
sauvetage de la compagnie gm avec
washington on s'en souviendra
à ce moment là il était également deux
sous-ministres ceux ci qui était
responsable du g7 de prime sur frau
était dans le g20 et là on a besoin des
meilleures pratiques aussi des idées des
autres pays pour lutter contre ce christ
d'une pandémie mondiale
c'est pas une concertation mondiale et
d'avoir un acteur comme défi est connu
c'est très important
il était le numéro 2 de mark carney il
était le favori en 2013 et finalement
jim flaherty à l'époque le ministre des
finances avait choisi stephen poloz
qu'est-ce que ça signale de de nommer un
homme avec l'expérience qu'il a avec la
feuille de route qu'il a comme tiff
macklem sur le rôle qui est attendu de
la part du gouverneur de la banque du
canada par ce gouvernement mais de la
main sans bien qu'être le numéro deux
depuis 20 ans c'est pas ce qui est de
mieux pour et voilà la bande ce cadeau
ceci étant donné que dans le fond comme
je dis un peu antérieurement convient
une grosse crise et que finalement y
aucun manuel d'instructions en termes
d'économie pas de manuels d'instructions
plaire ouvrir et il faudrait attendre
dans son index 50 euros et parmi
d'autres actions qui devront en effet de
la poste veut maintenant un plan fiscal
et monétaire pour s'assurer le conte à
une reprise soutenable et qu'on va
mettre sur une trajectoire soutenable
donc dans ce sens fait d'avoir quelqu'un
qui arrivent d'un peu de l'extérieur
mais il connaît très bien la machine
donc monté mardi au dessus de deux bords
se penser un peu en dehors du corps et
de sa servante une très bonne chose
c'est ce que son approche sera
différente de stephen poloz mais je
pense que yéyé très pragmatique et lui
s'il faut aller dans les tours négatif
même c'est un scénario assez voyagé s'il
faut aller contrôler la courbe de
rendement comme fait la banque du japon
dans un cocon avait une détérioration de
l'économie hésitera pas y aller dans ce
sens-là
il est très très pragmatique et je matin
que si besoin est
la banque du canada vos contribuent à
supporter les actions du groupe un
canadien il a parlé de tout et on lui a
parlé de tour négatif ce matin
bon il s'est avancé un petit peu
en laissant la possibilité à des taux
négatifs ce qui a fait chuter notre
dollar canadien aujourd'hui oui serait
pas fermé la porte alors que monsieur
paul a su fermer la porte à des détours
d'un actif lui a laissé la porte ouverte
parce que même si c'est un scénario
alternatif d'avoir une deuxième vague
mince on pense que l'économie va
rebondir au troisième trimestre on sait
jamais vous savez donc dans ce sens là
on est vu la réaction sur le dollar
canadien puisque à ce moment-là il
demain sa maigreur de leur 15e plus
ferme en même temps ça va être coton
concurrence et du canada gardons à
l'esprit qu'on est un exportateur de
pétrole ni le seul pic g7 et il faudra
peut-être composer avec ce game en avril
2018 il avait été nommé président d'une
table d'experts quatre experts sur la
finance durable
est ce que cette expertise sur les
changements climatiques est importante
pour diriger la banque du canada de nos
jours mais je pense que willow dans
l'environnement qu'on est rendu
évidemment toute la coque pression au
niveau de l'environnement c'est un est
où on voit main dans le secteur des
marchés financiers mais ni moscou ni son
ami on parle lui également dans ce sens
là et tant que c'est un manque de
commerces également de ce gouvernement
qu'on ait deux reprises développement
mais aussi durable
le fait qu'on a une personne qui est en
fait impliqué là dedans c'est d'acheter
certaines mais sa candidature est ce que
ça change quelque chose pour les
citoyens qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui
d'avoir un nouveau gouverneur à la
banque du canada
maëlys neuf chiens de gamins sur la
protection de pouvoir d'achat donc dans
ce sens le 6 éviter que j'avais toutes
les deux qui dit et combien que dans
trois quatre cinq ans que tout d'un coup
l'inflation repart donc c'est le
protecteur de la non pas de la devise
canadienne mettent en valeur de ne
pouvoir verso et tandis que son
expertise également que des finances
publiques et ses capacités à prendre la
parole la place publique et de façon
indépendante
il y aura peut-être des ti message fort
lancé si oui qu'est un peu des
disciplines pour le retour vers une
trajectoire durable des finances au
niveau les clés des finances publiques
la whey mais il ya toujours indépendance
entre la banque centrale et le ministère
des finances
même si c'est une liste des finances qui
approuvent la nomination du gouverneur
de la banque du canada
oui parce que le
conseil d'administration de la banque du
canada fait qu'une fois qu'il est nommé
les lieux pour certains et c'est
évidemment un conseil d'administration
mais ça ce fait vous savez main dans la
main on a une crise important d'être
humain on veut éviter que ce soit une
crise financière
c'est important d'avoir une bonne chimie
entre le ministère des finances et la
banque du canada
merci beaucoup clément gignac les
squares et merci